[Music]
and daredevil death news on guarantee
you it's a white person that's racist an
American white person American white
person because there are the ones who do
all crazy with rhyming first and last
names Evel Knievel Oh with the Red Bull
sponsorship submitted by Antoine B Sam
jams a 26 year old daredevil has died
after falling from a 62 storey
skyscraper in China Oh like a freebase
you might be wrong as a Chinese I'm
putting money on this what is he what is
it really
that's another good reason because
everything in Chinese breaks on you so
maybe he was up there just doing a
normal thing and then the whole thing
shattered and you felt weight cuz his
little cups were made in China
little things in the spy just oh yeah
you don't watch Mission Impossible
it's like cupping yeah see we don't know
[ __ ] about this we just see movies I
don't like high-tech like chameleon ones
when they stick on I just thought they
were plungers that you that's a cartoon
Bravo neither do they use them to hold
on the glass right in real life Lee is a
cotton ball they light it with fire and
then they take the suction on the oval
is that right yeah and then they go I
don't know anything
no cupping is what they do on there like
on your back and your muscles Oh oddly
enough my former stepmom got called into
the school because they thought the shoe
is abusing my little brother cuz she
cupped him and they saw the bruises and
she had to go to Cole like a perfect
circle what the [ __ ] did they justify
help speeding with the plunger so she
smacked me yeah she literally went to
court what the cupping Martin said look
this is what we do and they're like will
they do it now for physical therapy
right what does it call the thing now
still called cup yeah thought they would
come up with a cool scientific name for
it like makes you chill or something
it's like it uh it breaks up like scar
tissue just a lot of difference oh
really I mean there's the the Chinese
explanation like [ __ ] pulling out
spirits yeah does the Western like
people are breaking up scar tissue
increasing circulation moving body a
demo
like that kind of stuff yeah that's like
how they light what do you light incense
and [ __ ] and like supposed to clear out
your soul or some [ __ ] and then like the
Western thing is it smells pretty good
[Laughter]
like a pot of steaming like boiling um
herbal leaves and then it like steamed
up and they should put me vixa to pot
and throw a blanket over me hotbox the
most it's just vicks vapor rub
pretty much it's like old-school
eucalyptus oil in a steamer yeah yeah so
this daredevil this Chinese daredevil
Wow his name was woo young meme and so
he was a martial arts trained stuntman
oh no he had background in film he was
known to do this thing called rooftop
beam move topping you know what's one
thing I always forget I always forget
that China is its own like country and
world and also like a superpower so like
I follow like jiu-jitsu oh geez and
stuff like that and then don't be like
Chinese Brazilian jiu-jitsu competitions
or Chinese dance competitions and all
these things I'm like holy [ __ ] cuz I
I'm like so like American thinking that
I'm thinking that everything happens in
America and if you want to do like dope
[ __ ] you usually travel to America like
people that come here to pursue
Hollywood or they come here to do it but
then they have their own complete
industry over there so when I saw two
Chinese Brazilian Jiu Jitsu guys
grappling it like trip me the [ __ ] out
like I thought that they were two Asian
Americans from America going over see
everything just happens here yeah I got
a little bit and everyone over there's
just growing rice and [ __ ] yeah so I
thought it's very rare to find countries
with complete industry the way that I
usually the countries have their [ __ ]
you know like they like Japan has tech
what's Chinese Hollywood like dude
horrible sorry rude like that it's come
hard when I picture Chinese yeah it's
just kung fu movie and dramas
yeah or that's just what we know yeah
but they have their own they have
everything dance like they have their
own [ __ ] it's another planet I was
flying China air to Bali
I'm so sorry commercial like I guess was
starring some Chinese famous actor
probably the most famous person in China
and to me
like mom we all we know is Jackie Chan
and Jet Li yo Tony sometimes Lucy Liu
know she's Asian American and yummy yeah
yeah he's Chinese with the deepest voice
ever
yes but back to this dude biggest
Chinese dick ever probably yeah
hopefully in history probably oh whoa
he he was 26 years old here's some
photos of him roof topping oh he was
this right before the plunge of his bill
no I actually have a video of that oh
they caught that [ __ ] on video fall when
he let go of the building do you guys
wanna see yeah so he's holding on to
like the tip of the building that's what
he was doing in that other dude man
[ __ ] play stupid games Winston for
prizes I can't even [ __ ] say [ __ ] boy
yes like something experienced yeah I
know I'm just just a crazy person that
makes my balls tingle look man Instagram
wise he was like vampire kick she does
Instagram wise I'm jealous cuz I want
pictures like that on my Instagram but
just Green screaming I need that for
validation he's awesome and green
screening looks just as good yep
he was awesome so here's the video I'm
so sorry dude that sucks dude this for a
movie No
so the whole reason like he was roof
topping this time with his human taking
part in some sort of competition which
they haven't named who the sponsor was
but yes I wonder why yes so they they
were saying that the prize money was
about $15,000 and so he was gonna use
that money to propose to his girlfriend
the next day yeah and also pay for his
mom's like his mom's sick and implant
very well but like what if the insurance
policy here for this competition
like for real there's no such tans
insurance policy how do you talk to your
mom about that cuz you know I took my
mom on the phone about stuff like is he
like he's like mom is roof topping
things in a workout like what do you say
like is that what you say warning guys
graphic warning well I mean you don't
really see anything but you know what
happens at graphic imaginary warning
whirring here we go buddy oh he's he's
like oh [ __ ] I [ __ ] up you could tell
right there's nothing old competition is
no equipment that's the whole point of
the competition a spotter man wait oh my
[ __ ] god
who's recording it they don't think
that's [ __ ] crazy make one mistake
and you can't get your foothold and it's
over there was no one there just like
where he's like help and then just get
even fall into that position into that
position yeah cuz like yet or did he
climb down to that position I'm not sure
they don't specify which part like the
his climbing they were doing oh dude
they're covering all this [ __ ] up so no
one gets in trouble oh yeah that doesn't
seem like a well-thought-out event cuz
you should have like in any sport or in
any competition they always have like an
ambulance on standby they have people
like a fellow Chinese competitions are
different yeah well even for stunt
people some people there they work just
for for the catered meal yeah yeah like
when they have film shoots and stuff
they have a whole stunt team that'll
just work for food Wow
so that's how Jackie Chan's team was
first when they first started and then
they don't use pads they just used
cardboard so they they flat out well I
don't know about now but then the
stories of Jackie and in his days they
would just pile on cardboard and fall on
top of that good lord
yeah they manufacture [ __ ]
trampolines I don't know why they can't
just put like a Sunday they had someone
there as soon as he's like [ __ ] I need
an assistance then automatically you
just be out of the comp you know that
gets the call for help then at least his
life is spared and that's it he's out
disqualified yeah safety net dude at
least a safety bug that's horrible that
sucks
this guy should've just bought that
point him on a very uh so on the same
note but very different and so far
removed from this poor tragic event I
would want to feel what it feels like to
just kind of fall fall exceedingly
building yeah yeah yeah yeah but I think
that's the best that compress the the
difference the difference he only is
climbing these buildings there is the
risk of no safety yeah so that's a
completely different field yeah when you
know you have a pair of
it's like having sex in public versus
having sex in your bedroom very sure you
run the risk of getting caught 66 floors
that's a long fall that's 60 to 62
that's a long fall to think about how
[ __ ] you are I know that's the worst
part about it that's all I am on a
roller coaster I'm always like right as
it's going up I'm like god I hate this I
hate this I hate this [ __ ] cuz it's like
get it over with already
just let me go down now cuz I hate this
[ __ ] you know you know like roller
coasters I don't like the anticipation
part I like the roller-coaster part but
the waiting part all that I love that I
hate that part I like you when it's
climbing up but the one that I hate it's
like supreme scream or something like
you know when you're up and they're just
heavy yeah right I don't know where and
then they do that [ __ ] to you were like
do it and they don't go come on man it's
like sex right like I don't like having
sex I like the end part just put it in
there and wait I just always want to I'm
always so thirsty you just want to hurry
up and finish yeah I'm like you should
make a sexy-looking Camelbak for sex sex
like a flash covered one so you can't
just you know just doesn't look like
like you're dead like dad gear wait you
met you were literally thirsty I thought
you were making a metaphor no I'm not at
all I'm like literally thirsty as hell
yeah I'm like goddamn it like this is a
lot of work like I need a drink water
thirsty sexer weird cuz I'm like cardio
so sex is like the worst ya know a lot
of people are really shocked by this cuz
he would come out and a lot of
advertisements in social media and he's
a stuntman my rooftop events he would
come to his reception for his funerals
at a rooftop bar I mean right he
probably would have no other way
he Paul wants and the scatter his ashes
often people have you seeing that I
don't know where they offer it but like
you it's a dining experience where
you're Hank yeah we were supposed to go
to that but then it turned out to be
like a scam one it was in LA we your
hand
so
they have like I don't know what how
does it work the table is being dangled
the table and the chairs are being
dangled by ropes and you just sit there
strapped in and your legs are just like
floating on the limb and then you have
like a full course like three-course
meal being served I would just complain
the whole time about how I'm like
suspended in the air if I drop my fork
I just find something to complain about
the whole time is like that's what you
signed up for dude that is so stupid
what happens if you had a piece we are
so bored that our office mm-hmm at the
bottom you want to point that out so
that everyone knows yeah thanks it looks
like somewhere in Europe
I hope the Foods good because usually
these gimmicky things [ __ ] are
horrible food
[Music]